this is where most foreign aid arrives
in Sudan ships unloaded here and planes
at the airport up to 3 000 tons of food
tents blankets and medical supplies have
been donated but getting the aid to the
victims quickly and fairly is still an
issue
the governor of Khartoum is here to ask
the committee managing the aid to do
more to help his city
regarding the distribution of
humanitarian Aid we told the ministry in
charge that the area of Khartoum is the
most badly affected by the war and yet
there's a shortage in the aid it
receives we stress the need to improve
coordination in order to bring Aid to
the largest number of people who are
really in need we also like to debunk
the rumors that some of the aid is being
sold in Marketplace instead of reaching
the victims
Aid agencies are asking for better
coordination from the authorities
so it's really a humanitarian
catastrophe it's almost the third month
of War there's 2.9 people that are being
displaced all across Sudan and across
the borders ready to help and the thing
is that there's a lot of obstacles for
us to work in Sudan especially getting
people inside the country getting
supplies inside the country just an
example there's a hundreds of visas from
International ad workers they're ready
to come to Sudan and just being withheld
for the past month and a half Sudan has
been facing economic difficulties for
years but since fighting between the
Army and the rapid support forces
militia began in April people employed
by the government are facing even more
hardships
we also briefed the meeting about the
situation of the public sector employees
they haven't received salaries for the
last three months which has a huge
impact on their livelihood most of them
are from low economic categories their
poverty has been deepened by the war the
bank of Sudan and mystery of Finance
said they will deal with the problem
within a week we urge them to do so so
nearly every single civilian in this
country has been affected by the
conflict
normal life as they know it has come to
a standstill but on the other hand there
is a huge amount of resilience hope and
above all patience
Port Sudan